thanks dad you know this is an honor
I've waited for my entire life in fact I
when I was seven I wrote a speech bring
with me up a reunion should I read it
[Applause]
well if you insist
[Laughter]
friends duvets and guests I am honored
to be your grill master it's an
achievement I rank up there with my
black belt in Taekwondo never did that
yeah never did that a quick-thinking up
grandpa Charles he's dead
sad didn't do that
Mary mom I was seven again when I wrote
this
so still seems kinda old to want to do
that really should have looked over this
at some point
since then oh and never getting in a car
with a stranger
cuz stranger danger never did that so
and you shouldn't so that's a good thing
kids learn from it
oh thank you God thank you very much son